we have a very special story just
by the way would you just please
but first we have a very special story
to start the show
thanking someone and showing gratitude
can be a very powerful thing and today's
big thank you
[Music]
goes to gina goodwin a nurse wife
foster mother from peabody massachusetts
gina is making headlines for cooking and
delivering
hundreds of meals to people in need
every thanksgiving
gina has already received over a
thousand dinner orders
and her community is already lined up
to thank her please take a look i've
known gina for 15 years and she's one of
the most giving and caring
and most loving people i've ever met so
gina's a nurse
and that's just naturally one of the
most giving professions that there is
it's just
who she is gina has no clue of the
amazing
inspiring positive impact that she is
having on our community
gina started five years ago feeding 200
people
and now this year she's up over 1 000
people that she'll be feeding
this thanksgiving what gina has been
doing with the meals is simply amazing
a mother of six taking her time to cook
i mean it's an undertaking that
i couldn't do this is a different year
people have lost jobs they've lost loved
ones
they're coming home from the hospital
gina has given people hope so
gina's that person who she doesn't want
the acknowledgement but she
deserves it this holiday is going to be
extremely
hard for our family and i am grateful
for gina to extend a hand gina
i don't know how this community
would run without you she
is the most generous person i've
ever imagined will ever meet
gina will join us soon and has no idea
that a big thank you is coming her way
first
let's meet one of the people we just
heard from jackie willis hi
jackie hi crew how are you
hi how are you i'm hanging in
um may i start with asking like how
gina has impacted your life
absolutely um i am a nurse
like gina um we've worked together many
times
um four years ago due to children's
medical issues
um i had to become a stay-at-home mom
and my husband who's a teacher and a
coach
had to provide for our family
and this year with coved his day got
cut short and so as salary is
so gina posted on facebook
um she took care of her community and
asked if anybody else wanted
or needed other meals and i
reached out to her embarrassingly i
reached out to her because we could use
a helping hand and gina
graciously said no problem of course
i can only imagine how hard that must be
to have to
put yourself out there to ask for help
watching you speak and do you think
that out of having to extend yourself
and be so vulnerable out there
was someone like gina able to
put something positive in a very
vulnerable place
oh absolutely gina would
give you the shirt off her back without
even thinking twice
so even though i was embarrassed
i had no problem asking
her for help because working together
and working in the community together
for such a long time
i've seen how she is and
see how she gives back to her
communities in many
ways than just this way so
i have no problem asking her for help
she's such a great person
every time i hear stories like this i
just think about the kind of
person we all wish we could be that we
strive to be
and things like the holidays come up and
you think about
the important work that people do that
is just the example
of what human beings are capable of
and you want to be like them and it just
seems like
gina really is that person that
i i wish i could be like her um i mean
if you could say anything to her may i
ask what you would
say to her i don't think i have enough
words to say to her
um thank you from my family
thank you from peabody thank you for
massachusetts
for being the person that you are
everyone should look at your example
and try to strive to be like you are
every day it would make the world such a
better place
that is really well said i have to say
jackie that is
exactly right and um we want to give you
the chance to tell her that yourself
um if if you don't mind when we come
back oh absolutely
okay okay great let's honor gina and
surprise her with a big
thank you today is all about giving back
and giving thanks with our big thank you
we just learned about gina goodwin a
massachusetts nurse who has been
donating meals to those in need
and the living example please welcome
gina
hi gina thank you so much for having me
gina
what's the secret i want to be like you
i want my kids to be like you i want to
live my life by your example
i'm not kidding how how do you how do
you be like you
you you just do it dro you you don't
think about it you don't stop to worry
about it you don't
wonder how you're gonna do it you just
do it you
just say okay i'm gonna do this and you
find a way
and you know what everybody wants to
help
there's people that are coming out of
the woodwork left and right you know can
i cook for you can i deliver for you
can i shop for you can i donate money i
mean
everybody wants to help and it's just
not it's a team
i i still see a lot of credit going your
way there because they're wanting to
help
by facilitating your example i just
really appreciate
that you're taking care of all these
people and providing these meals
and taking the initiative and the
follow-through
and everything that it takes to be you
can i ask like was it just the holidays
in general because i do feel like that's
a time
that we all sort of get in touch with
deeper things
uh or what was it about the holidays
that made you go
this is my time five years ago that was
my
that was my thinking it's the holidays
maybe we could feed some people
that are less fortunate maybe i could
teach my children what it's like to give
back
you know the holidays are not the most
wonderful of the year for some people
i know that's what the world wants to
believe that the holidays are the most
wonderful time of the year
they're not for some people the people
there's a lot of people that dread it
there's a lot of people that want to
skip the month of november and december
they you have maybe lost a loved one or
financially they're struggling and they
can't provide for their family
um so us being able to at least give
them a new
good meal um you know i have a friend
and
she she was kind of struggling a little
bit her child was sick um
and she had some financial issues and
she contacted me
and i said yeah you know i got a
donation here's a donation for you
buy yourself in your family an entire
holiday meal
and that's what it's about may i ask is
that
friend is her name jackie
yes okay interesting
um well i
i have someone here uh actually that has
a message for you
jackie are you there hi gina
hi guys um jackie what did you
want to say uh to gina well
first thank you from my family
i know we relate with the medical issues
and the stuff that we've been going
through because we've been in constant
contact
so thank you from us it really means a
lot this year
it really means a lot also thank you
from your community
because i was out there with you
helping people you know day and night
and i know they can't come on here and
thank you
thank you for them i know you don't like
to
to hear thank yous but you are doing so
much more and you are teaching your kids
so much and i hope
your tea you're teaching my kids you
know i've talked about you
your tea you're teaching how the world
to be a better place
it's really true gina i hear your story
and
i think it's an important reminder of
what is
needed during the holidays and what we
can all step up to the plate
and do and uh gina um
we wanted to start off this week with a
big
thank you uh from our friends at whole
foods
who want to be able to help nourish your
community this holiday season
so they are giving a five thousand
dollar gift card
to easily shop their 365 buy whole foods
items
from their private brand available at
all the whole foods
and um jackie also uh
we wanted to just participate in your
holiday
as well and um also match that
and give you guys five thousand dollars
to say happy thanksgiving
and thank you so much
and um i'm gonna match that for both of
you so
it'll be ten thousand dollars to each of
you and i just
wanna say thank you for
all that you're doing in the world and
all that you're showing
and teaching us and if it's okay
i would like to stay in touch and
keep learning from you guys and keep
checking in
and see how it's all going see what else
i can do as just the individual i
am to participate so it is the big thank
you and i thank you
thank you so much